so one of the really common sort of uh
oxymoronic phenomena that we see in
american politics is that the people
that you sometimes see most loudly
shouting about how the constitution says
i get to do something or the
constitution says you don't get to do
something or you don't get to force me
to do something the people most loudly
shouting that type of stuff are often
the people who least understand the
constitution we've seen this with free
speech we've we've talked to first
amendment experts about how the people
most loudly and most frequently yelling
about free speech and the first
amendment actually don't understand it
um in the covet era in the pandemic era
that same constitutional confusion as we
might call it applies
to vaccination
very very uh analogously and more and
more we're hearing that listen it's in
the constitution
you don't have to get vaccinated if you
don't want to you can't violate my
constitutional rights
by forcing me to get vaccinated we hear
that any vaccine mandate
would be a violation of your
constitutional rights and this actually
couldn't be more wrong now i want to be
really clear because sometimes when we
do a conversation like this
people wrongly think i'm
saying something that i'm not actually
saying
the issue of the legality of vaccine
mandates in general by a government
is a topic of much legal discussion and
there isn't 100 agreement about could
the federal government mandate a vaccine
versus would it have to be done at the
state level or whatever the case may be
but it is not a constitutional issue
period and there's actually precedent
which we will talk to uh talk about in a
moment um so we can make a moral case
for a vaccination requirement but that's
not actually what this is about we could
make a cultural or a public health case
for a vaccination requirement but again
that's not actually today's topic
there is no constitutional case
against vaccine requirements so let's go
through the likely arguments that the
anti-vaxxers would make along these
grounds
they might say a vaccine mandate
violates the first amendment to the
constitution they might say a vaccine
mandate violates the fifth amendment to
the constitution and sometimes they say
a vaccine mandate would violate the 14th
amendment to the constitution now the
first amendment protects speech the
fifth religion and the fourteenth the
right not to be quote deprived of life
liberty or property without due process
of law
i don't believe any of these would hold
up but this is not a show where i give
legal opinions i come up with because
legal is not my area of expertise my
assessment is just
what do the legal opinions say about
exactly this issue and i've told you
before that in the early 20th century
there was a legal controversy over
maxine mandates not dissimilar to the
one we're seeing today and it took place
in massachusetts and it was surrounding
smallpox and the supreme court decided
in 1905
against a guy
who refused to get the smallpox vaccine
uh the the supreme court decided that
the state's uh vaccine requirement
slash the city of cambridge's vaccine
requirement
was perfectly fine
saying that your liberty stops
at its likelihood to damage
or do harm to other people it's actually
a relatively simple concept even in
libertarian circles sane libertarian
circles this is the case
of jacobson v massachusetts you can
google the case there's a very simple
wiki article explaining what it's all
about
so there is supreme court uh precedent
for enforcing vaccine mandates that
ruling from 1905 has been referenced
repeatedly even in the covet era even in
the covetera by the supreme court
when vaccine requirements have been
upheld this 1905 case has been
referenced now in terms of speech
generally
the government can prohibit behavior
that is generally protected by the first
amendment
if it is demonstrably to save lives to
preserve life and the infamous kind of
prototypical example
is the government can ban yelling fire
in a crowded theater even though
speaking and saying the word fire
generally
is protected speech speaking is
protected speech but this is a case
where the government can actually say uh
you can't do that and people might say
but sir that's my free speech that goes
beyond free speech it goes into public
safety and the fact that yelling fire in
a crowded theater is likely much like a
ton of people refusing to get vaccinated
to have a predictable deleterious
harmful effect on public health and on
people
now there is another issue here which i
think i should mention
and it's the issue of hypocrisy there is
almost always hypocrisy from these
right-wingers my body my choice on the
vaccine
same with the woman's right to choose
right no oh no no no that should be
illegal wait i said what
that's a double standard and we'll talk
tomorrow about what's going on with the
texas abortion law and here with the
case of the vaccines
many of those opposing the vaccine
mandates
because its government overreach
had no problem with the patriot act ndaa
mass surveillance etc
the same people who have been fighting
for decades for businesses to have all
the power
and the employees to have none
suddenly want to take away the right of
a business to say hey our business
decision is that our employees have to
be vaccinated our business decision
which conservatives have said for
decades we should have we should be able
to make decisions that are best for us
our decision is customers must be
vaccinated all of a sudden now they're
against that so yes they're pathetic
yes they are hypocrites but they're also
wrong on the facts and that's a unique
combination pathetic hypocritical and
wrong on the facts and on the
constitutionality of vaccination
mandates you do not have a
constitutional right not to get
vaccinated the details of vaccine
mandates if we see them are going to be
adjudicated and we'll we'll handle them
one by one but that blanket it's almost
used like a cudgel
uh that that's a violation of the
constitution really which which part of
the constitution or bill of rights and
the arguments very very quickly fall
apart we'll have more on this
as i assume
uh i expect maybe is a better way to say
it i expect that there will be more
legal decisions about vaccination
requirements and mandates upcoming
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video